good morning you've just seen the
nominees for best achievement and long
commercials and the winner is
the Academy they could use the money
anyway George Bernard Shaw died at 94
never having seen my fair lady
the musical based on his great play I
think if you've been able to hold out
for opening night he probably still be
with us he probably still be applauding
Julie Andrews as his beloved Liza and
tonight to present for us the award for
the best foreign language film our fair
lady Miss Julie Andrews
those nominated for the best foreign
language film of the year are Federico
Fellini's eight-and-a-half achene Aires
production from Italy nice in the water
a camera unit of film Polsky production
from hurry of it lost Toronto's Cathy's
assumes RV from Spain the Red Lanterns
Damascus and Michael Eady's AE from
Greece and the twin sisters of Kyoto
shochiku Company Limited from Japan and
the winner is winner is Italy Federico
Fellini
I am particularly happy to receive these
photo tabulous over because it comes to
me on XIV of my next picture and I don't
think that a director about to start his
new job could wish for anything more
stimulating and auspicious of this I
want you all to accept my deepest and
more intense arrivederci buona fortuna